جرعه تفاؤل يصبها استطلاع رايا على الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الساعي لنيل
الانتخابات عام 2024 التي تمثل بنسبه اليه
معركه وجوديه حيث اظهر استطلاع لارى
ناخبين الجمهوريين ان اكثر من نصفهم حوالي
54% يدعمون ترشح الرئيس السابق ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العام المقبل وبحسب
استطلاع الاراء الذي اجرته شبكه فوكس نيوز
الامريكيه فان عدد الدعم لترشح ترامب
يتجاوز ضعف عدد المؤيدين لحاكم ولايه
ابلوريدا رون ديسنتيس وذكر الاستطلاع ايضا
الذي اجري في الفتره من الرابع والعشرين
الى السبع والعشرين من مارس الذي شمل 107
اشخاص ان ديسنتيس حصل على دعم 24% من
المستجيبين في حين ارتفع تصنيف ترامب
بمقدار 11% منذ فبراير الماضي في حين
انخفض دعم ديسنتيس بنسبه اربعه في المئه